[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin oberwachtmeister und kaffee zu
gegenüberstellung 23 meinen funktionen
es ist gucken kommen
[Musik]
wenn der heutige zehn spielen wir ein
zugriff durch ihr fabrikgelände falls
nötig auch unter feuer
[Musik]
ich bin ihre so alt bin ist das bedeutet
dass ich meiner gruppe den umgang mit
dem gewidmet beibringen um die
hochgebirgs tauglich zu machen
[Musik]
meine aufgaben sind beobachten und
jedenfalls bekämpfen von weizsäcker
spezial zählen zwei der damen ist
wichtig auf den untergrund sagten
felsiges gelände diese putziges gelände
daraufhin werde angepasst und die
gerätschaften daran angepasst
[Applaus]